now good afternoon i'm bianca holman
bail denied for the landlord accused of
murdering two tenants and critically
injuring a third arnold lozano sanchez
was arrested yesterday following the
shooting on chicago avenue off
industrial near wyoming hector mejia
live from the regional justice center in
downtown las vegas where he's appeared a
four before a judge a short time ago
hector
[Music]
the public defender had asked for a 25
thousand dollars bail with house arrest
but the judge denied that request saying
these are very serious allegations and
wearing jail clothing arnaldo lozano
sanchez faced a judge for the first time
this morning the 78-year-old faces three
felony charges two counts of open murder
and one count of attempted murder lozano
sanchez's first words were in spanish in
court he said he did not know what he
was being accused of but prosecutors
said the defendant was not just trying
to terrorize the victims he was trying
to kill them according to the arrest
report he shot and killed two women and
critically injured a man shooting him
nine times all over unpaid rent
according to authorities and during bail
arguments the court brought up a
chilling account from a witness that
said lozano sanchez was laughing and
smiling after opening up this early
stage of proceedings i am going to order
that mr sanchez be detained without
bail the 78-year-old man rented rooms in
his home to various people also stated
in his arrest report he told a witness
that some were not paying him and that
he would quote handle this his way
police say he even tried to hide the gun
with neighbors it was later found under
a bush the next court appearance is set
for august the 16th as for the
identities of the two women who died the
clark county coroner's office is not
ready to release their names yet as they
are still working to notify all their
family members reporting in downtown
hector mejia 8 news now